high school he almost got expelled
because he was leading a revolt against
the principal
please welcome hamdan
thank you Jared thank you to the New
York art conference for having me back
it's my second year here who was here
last year by round of applause
a lot of folks very cool
very very excited to be back
um so last year I came here I spoke
about my work in emoji data science
which is a big passion of mine that's
one of my uh that's me at the world's
first ever Emoji conference emojicon you
have to hold these emojis and they take
pictures of you it's it's really cool
um
today I wanted to take a step back and
talk a little bit about sort of my
thoughts on the field and kind of like
what really excites me and gets me
passionate about data science because
I've kind of been been in it for a
little while now it's just something
that I'm deeply passionate about
um so last year yeah I talked about
Emoji data science I did the world's
first study on the peach Emoji that's
one of my claims to fame
um I think that's Mashable or one of the
one of those Outlets
um I yeah I mean that's what I found
basically if you want to know how the
peach Emoji gets used that's how it's
used
it's uh it's very cool no one would have
expected that
um and then you can also look at the
Emojis people use with the peach no
surprise it's the eggplant
um and then you know I also did some
work on the Taylor Swift Kanye West Feud
I don't know if you guys were familiar
with that that was a big thing like I
think six seven years ago I don't know
who ended up winning I guess I don't
know Kanye Roundup Applause
no Taylor Taylor everyone loves Taylor
okay yeah Kanye went off the deep end
anyway
um I looked into that I documented the
world's first ever instance of snake
bombing that's when people started
leaving the snake Emoji comment on
Taylor's profile on Instagram on Twitter
uh Instagram actually banned the snake
Emoji for 48 hours because it was a case
of cyber bullying
um kind of wild stuff but you know today
I really wanted to take a step back I
want to start at the origin so this is
me in high school I actually just found
this picture I went to the Bronx High
School of Science here in New York I
don't have any New York natives in the
house
um very nerdy school
um as you can tell that's how I dressed
in high school
today I like they made me leave the
jacket because they're like it's 100
degrees you got it you know you have to
relax a little and I have had a lot of
coffee and that's me in high school you
know studying R right no that's not true
I'm not that old but uh you know I've
kind of been in this field for you know
a while uh back in uh I end let me sort
of
okay where am I going to go so I've been
in this field a while so I think for me
it's really interesting to consider what
data science is like today and how it
started out when I got into it so these
are two quotes that I really like
um you know one is from Eric Fromm who's
a great 20th century psychologist
philosopher he talked about how we're
enmeshed internet of means and we've
lost sight of the ends we have all of
these incredible tools but we don't
really know what to use them for and the
second one is this very famous quote by
Jeff Hammer Barker where he talked about
how the best minds of our generation are
thinking about how to make people click
ads and the reason why I always found
these quotes So poignant and pertinent
is because it seems that today
increasingly data science is being
reduced to a set of tools a set of
powerful tools but we're not thoughtful
enough about now that we have these
tools what do we do with them so I don't
know if you guys have seen a data
science resume these days
um I hire a lot and you know we get like
300 resumes and almost all of them have
a box like this like I guarantee it I'm
seeing people nodding your resumes have
a box like this I don't blame you
everyone does right and it's like this
box of all of these buzzwords that like
you have to put on your resume because
everyone's like this is data science and
you have to know all of these tools and
I don't even know what data stage is uh
I don't I don't know what Seaborn is I
guess it's cool cognos like all of these
all these mumbo-jumbo words when like
for me data science is actually about
solving problems it's about finding
insights it's about learning something
about how the world works it's about
pursuing our deepest curiosity and you
know I think in the old days when you
would ask people why do you want to
become a data scientist the types of
answers they would give would be very
big picture answers they'd be like I
want to understand how stars get formed
and I want to understand why some
societies succeed economically why
others fail like I want to they would
come up with really powerful answers and
now when you ask people why do you want
to become a data scientist they give you
a list of tools like this right like I
want to do this I want to do this and
it's like there's nothing necessarily
inherently wrong with that but I just
wanted to sort of walk you through a
little bit of my journey and I think
what I find so powerful about the
promise of data science and I don't know
if you guys remember there was this
article in Harvard Business Review in
2012 that sort of kicked off a lot of
this passion for data science that's
when they called it data scientists the
sexiest job of the 21st century
um no one in my family knew what data
science was before then I sent this to
my family I sent it to all my friends
and they were like wow that's so cool
you're a data scientist now we get it
um because back then really people
didn't really know what it was and if
you go back and and read those articles
the vision of data science is very
different from this sort of toolbox data
science that that we have today where
back then how Varian who was Google's
Chief Economist essentially their Chief
data scientist he talked about how the
power of data science has the ability to
understand data process it find Value
and it visualize it communicate it he's
not talking about machine learning over
here he's not talking about deep
learning he's not talking about AI now a
lot of those tools have developed
recently they're very powerful tools but
I think the original vision of data
science was much more holistic it was
much broader it was much more
human-centric it was really about human
beings it was about people it was about
finding important questions and
answering them and you know this is what
got me into the field so I dug up my
statement of purpose when I applied to
grad school and uh you know this is what
I wrote in that statement it was about
data sets telling me their stories it
was about understanding the world and
that is what you know I found so
powerful about it and I think a lot of
people so they don't fully appreciate
that data science is deeply human you
know this is sort of how I view that
data science process where it starts out
by finding a problem to solve and then
you find the data to answer this
question you clean the data you analyze
the data you build models you do some
technical stuff and then you have to
tell a story you have to use that story
to have impact if you look at these you
know steps in the data science process
the vast majority of these are actually
really deep human skills right there's
no uh python notebook that's going to
tell you how to find a good problem to
solve right there's no Library that's
going to tell you how do you find the
data to answer your question and I think
this is what really
excites me about data science and this
is sort of what I want to bring back to
the audience and sort of share a little
bit about my journey and how I've done
this throughout my career and I think
going back to the permit the title right
data science is permissionless the
reason I say that is because so many
people are always asking how do I become
a data scientist how do I break into
data science like open your LinkedIn any
day there's like 20 kids right messaging
me like how do I do it how do I do it
every I don't know how to do it and it
assumes that there's this massive
barrier to entry to becoming a data
scientist data scientists is not like
brain surgery where you need to you need
someone to let you operate on their
brain to become a brain surgeon right
you can't just become a permissionless
brain surgeon it doesn't work like that
if you want to go out and build Bridges
like you need someone to hire you to
build a bridge and you need a lot of raw
material you need a lot of resources you
need you need stuff right you need
permission to be a bridge builder or
brain surgeon if you want to do data
science you actually don't need anyone's
permission you can do it that's it right
and that that was sort of was always my
ethos
um you just need to go out and find data
and data is more freely available today
than it ever has been which is
incredible
um and you just need the tools to
analyze that data and we have a lot of
powerful tools uh R which is what
brought us all together is a powerful
open source tool that allows you to find
incredible value in data which is why I
think we need to shift this mindset of
you know how do I enter data science and
how does someone give me a chance data
is everywhere right and so it's all
about you and finding value in that data
and I think this really hit home for me
when you know my younger sister came to
me about you know 10 years ago now and
she told me I want to become a community
organizer but I keep applying to these
Community organizer jobs and they all
want five years of experience they want
recommendations from politicians like
how do I become a community organizer
and I was just like why don't you just
go organize a community right I was she
was like what I can do that I was like
yeah core Community organizer organizing
Community she's like whoa and then she
went out and did that and now she works
in public policy at Google I'm very
proud of her but it's like that's how it
begins it's about take shifting our
mindset from you know there are these
Gatekeepers and you have to jump through
all these hoops
um and data science is one of these
fields where it's really really
powerfully true so data is all around us
the tools to understand this data are
widely available open source
well-documented the community is
fantastic so then the question is where
do you start okay like that sounds
really intimidating you just want me to
go ahead and do data science what does
that mean that sounds really scary and
for me the answer has always been start
with your passion start with things you
care about because the skills you have
as a data scientist are not just for you
to do your day job and be great at that
which we do that all of that and that's
incredible they're there to help you
pursue your curiosity and find the
answers to questions that you care about
um that's what this skill set enables us
to do and I think that's really that's
really powerful
so you know I've had a wide and varied
and you know kind of wild journey across
my career I started out getting a
master's in biostatistics I dropped out
of a neuroscience PhD program I've
worked in politics I've worked in
advertising I've worked in emojis I
worked in finance I've kind of doing all
of these crazy things but for me I think
a lot of us when we think about the Arc
of our career and what motivates us for
me the Common Thread has always been we
have a lot of data and we have no idea
what to do with it that's like every job
I've ever walked into every interview
everyone we have a lot of people don't
know what to do with it again today I
think that scares people because I was
reading on blind if you go in an
interview and someone says that to you
run as fast as you can
um but for me like that got me excited
because it meant like okay I get to
build something from the ground up these
people have a lot of data they have no
idea what there is to do with it let's
start let's find stories in this data
let's find Value in this data and that
actually got me it got me really excited
and really helped drive my career so
today you know in the nine minutes I
have remaining I want to walk through
very quickly some examples in my career
of how I've used data science to pursue
my curiosity I'll talk a little bit
about my work in politics my work in
emojis and then lastly this project on
news deserts and we'll call it a day so
has anyone here worked on a political
campaign volunteered on a political
campaign a few people yeah how was it
you love them
you change your major from what to what
oh wow okay
very cool not the not what I was
expecting
um so I worked on a political campaign
so this was uh 2012.
um I was a research assistant at
Columbia business school I just dropped
out of my PhD program trying to figure
out what to do with my life and I get an
email Ron Paul is having a a winter
program in Iowa for people to come out
and volunteer for the caucuses and this
was right in December break it was
holiday break I loved Ron Paul right I
don't know of any Ron paulers in the
house any Libertarians
um okay that's cool
um uh I think back then you know I
really like that he wanted to end the
war he was pro-civil Liberties like
things that were very important back in
that period in American history and I'd
never been to Iowa like I grew up in New
York I grew up in Brooklyn I'd never
been to Iowa I imagine like it was going
to be beautiful corn fields and snow
everywhere that is what I would look
like when I got there there was no snow
anywhere it was uh it was empty there
was literally nothing around that's
literally a picture I took on my second
day in Iowa
um so I go to Iowa and it's a it's a
campaign right it's a it's a call center
essentially I walk in and there's a
phone we used to call them phone Banks
but essentially it's a call center you
have a hundred volunteers and all they
do is call voters all day hi I'm a
volunteer uh if the election were held
today who would you vote for uh Mitt
Romney Ron Paul and new Gingrich what
issue is most important to you
Healthcare the War veterans rights How
likely are you to vote they're
essentially polling voters
um and I walked in you know as a
volunteer so they're like okay grab a
phone get to work and here I am you know
Master's statistician
um but I did it I did it for a day and
then I walk up to the guy at the front
of the call center and I I basically
gave him my resume I said listen I'm a
statistician I don't know if you saw a
Money Ball like week I can really help
you guys turn this around my skills are
being underutilized on this phone
calling grandmas in Iowa like let's get
let's get rolling you know and he had no
idea what I was talking about he looked
at me like I was from Mars um this was
2012. it was way before Big Data
politics Obama all of that and he had no
idea what I was talking about that was
like a very eye-opening moment for me
because it was like you can't just you
have to show people what you can do for
them you have to actually show it to
them because otherwise they have no idea
what you're talking about
um so he went back he said I don't know
what you're talking about I'm sure
you're really smart I have an idea for
just the thing you can do for the
campaign I was like yes yes he's like
make some calls so I said so I spent
three days making calls in that phone
bank and then I went up to him again and
I said
um I can tell you how we can win this
election because I can tell you what
issues voters care about I can tell you
what parts of the state we're performing
well in I can even tell you who are the
highest performing Volunteers in this
call center I can tell you where Ron
Paul should visit next because these are
the parts of the state where we're about
to beat Newt Gingrich I can give you all
of that and it was like his mind
exploded he was like what like what you
can do all of that and I was like yeah I
can do it and he said where's your
computer log in right now and that's how
I became the national statistician in
Ron Paul's campaign
um literally and my SAS license had
expired because you know SAS was this
old software at Legacy software back in
the day still around still around my SAS
license had expired and I had like take
one of my professors had like covered r
a little bit so literally in the phone
Bank in Iowa I downloaded our I taught
myself how to use our on the Ron Paul
campaign in Iowa with that guy standing
over my shoulder because after I logged
in every 30 minutes he's like did you
find something did you find something
did you find something how are you going
to win how are you going to win how are
you going to win and it was just an
incredible experience because I
literally created that position for
myself out of nowhere and then I had all
of this data we started reporting on
that data this is what a dashboard
looked like in 2012. that's literally a
dashboard where we have we would update
it every hour on how many calls we had
made and what our support rate was and
what counties we were doing the best in
um and it was it was just incredible
right and then we ended up
um the screen going blank okay there we
go uh so we had these are Ron Paul's
granddaughters so one day so I basically
started building reports
um no I'll tell you why that's funny
because I started building reports on
who the most successful callers in that
phone bank were and I would just run
this report every hour and then they
would announce the results and all the
kids would start jumping up and down
because I was like you know these are
the kids who made the most calls these
are the kids who got the people to
answer the most surveys these are the
kids who were most effective at
persuading people to vote and I would
just run this every hour
um and then I would start building these
reports and we had that whiteboard
dashboard and then the the head of the
phone bank he came to me one day and he
said I want you to put stickers on every
single volunteer in this phone bank with
their statistics to motivate them to
perform better so that's the sticker I
am modeling on my suit it has my name it
has how many calls I've made it has my
percentile ranking in that phone bank
because I gave him the printout and he
said take a marker take a volunteer put
a sticker on every kid in this phone
bank that way he can know who's
performing the best it was wild for me
coming out of grad school where you know
like it's very slow it takes four years
to write a paper everything is like so
slow and here I am I came up with an
idea I wrote 10 lines of R and now every
kid in this phone Bank in Iowa is
wearing a sticker with numbers that I
came up with on my computer it was wild
to me
um and it was just fascinating right
because it was like I got to do all of
that from scratch it was incredible
experience eventually you know we found
the top Volunteers in that phone bank we
took them across the country with us we
took them across the country these are
the top like we literally traveled the
country and eventually we started doing
cooler stuff we started looking at Maps
we started doing more Geo targeting
looking at you know where in the state
we were performing best by now I'm sure
there's all these softwares for all of
this but back then this was literally
just me hacking it together in R and I
think that was such an incredible
rewarding experience for me because
literally it was just me taking
something I was passionate about finding
data and doing stuff with that data and
that ended up like opening so many doors
for me I I had so many interviews where
anyone would just ask me what is Ron
Paul like how what was it like working
on the campaign I had no technical
interviews basically those were my
interviews I would walk into a coding
interview and the guy would just be like
what is Ron Paul like it was wild 2012
fun days in data science
um but I think that's sort of like the
story here is that these opportunities
are all around us like there are things
that you're passionate about where
there's data where you can add value to
the world you can find insights you can
learn about stuff and that's just
incredible I want to talk briefly about
my work in emojis so again I did a lot
of work in emoji data science but that
also started kind of very randomly out
of whim I was working at Facebook my day
job was kind of boring I was doing ads
research working with advertisers and ad
agencies falling asleep in meetings and
one day I figured out we have a lot of
Text data on Facebook I want to figure
out what are the top emojis people use
on Facebook and I started poking around
in SQL And Hive it turns out it's
actually quite difficult to answer that
question back then at least because Hive
would garbled a Unicode encoding of the
ammonia so you couldn't really pull them
out so when I started Googling how do
you work with Emoji data and every
single NLP Library I found the first
line was hashtag remove emojis and
emoticons and I was like okay this is
not what I need but this was also an
eye-opening moment for me I was like if
everyone is removing the Emojis maybe I
should study only the Emojis and that's
what I ended up doing and it was kind of
incredible so Facebook ended up filing a
patent on emoji machine learning based
on based on this work which was really
cool basically this is the foundation of
emoji recommendation now so in your
phone when you type in a word it shows
you an emoji this was the early work
that sort of guided that that science
behind it I ended up doing a lot of work
on emojis I looked at the Emojis after
brexit happened
um and here are the top emojis when
brexit happened kind of like really
basic work I I you know I found that
when people are happy about brexit they
use the party hot Emoji when they're sad
about it they use the crying face emoji
stuff that's like super obvious to
everyone in this room but back then here
here's the thing here's the critical
Insight most almost all data scientists
in the world thought emojis were stupid
almost everyone who was passionate about
emojis was not a data scientist I was
the only one who was a data scientist
who loved emojis and that kind of became
my my competitive advantage and it was
just incredible I did the Kanye West
Taylor Swift thing I looked at emojis on
Election Day uh this clicker is really
annoying I'm gonna send her I looked at
emojis on Election Day so on the right
you have emojis that are so that people
use when they were talking about Donald
Trump on the left you have emojis that
people use when they're talking about
Hillary Clinton again you're really able
to capture the emotional state of a
Nation
um by finding value and data this is our
code everything on this chart is r and
you can find it on prismoji.com I have a
GitHub by now it's like eight years
outdated I think Twitter took down their
API so it's probably too late to become
an emoji data scientist using Twitter
data but I'm sure you guys are smart and
can figure something out but it was just
an incredible incredible journey
um these are this is what the middle
finger emoji means
um in case you guys were wondering I'm
waiting for my honorary PhD in
linguistics because of this it's coming
it's coming any day now and uh yeah I
mean you know basically I really want to
encourage you guys
um and motivate you that the best way to
become a data scientist is to do data
science and start with something you're
passionate about build some cool stuff
share it with the world you got this
thank you so much for having me it's a
pleasure being here
[Applause]